man you know what I'm going to say like
this I don't think he knows like I don't
think he meant it like that n whack's a
good dude bro no that's cool and I give
it I give every person the benefit of
the doubt but like like yeah I clown
around F but like I'm not playing out
here like I don't give a [__] for like
I'm really from where I'm from I don't
care about this [__] like you I'm from a
gang and I got my homies behind me and I
don't care I know he does talk down on
Mexicans I don't talk down on blacks I
do not I've been in jail that's cool I I
don't even know who the [__] he is dog
like I really don't I just did 9 years
in Pelican Bay he said like I never shot
[__] like he don't know me dog I'm the
best La rapper this a essay you better
check the [__] resume dog for
you talk about me dog on the gang I'm
really tripping like that dead homies I
don't give a [__] about this [__] talk
about him like that no I don't talk
about him like that or his people like
that that [__] ain't cool dog I'll never
do [__] with him dead homies bang that
it's like that I'm tripping like I'm
tripping dog like that [__] ain't cool
[__] him I said it [__] him it is what
it is dog we want to do a show there
wherever he's at [__] him